[Music]
it easy social study here's what the
Stars have been posting online Selena
Gomez appears to be making new music
again I've been in the studio letting it
sit for a minute
songwriter Justin Tranter posted this
pic of Selena putting on eyeliner on
Thursday but caption the snap music and
love I'm in a good spot right now and
check out these side by sides of Blake
Lively and daughter Jane they're
practically twins Blake and hubby Ryan
Reynolds debut their baby girls at his
Hollywood Walk of Fame ceremony on
Thursday and James who turns 2 today
stole the show looks like James might be
getting into showbiz or she looks antsy
to get into showbiz no no no there will
be no showbiz in her future unless she's
until she's 30 I think she's that's a
safe time for her to enter they enter
the game
Blake posted this pic from the ceremony
adding crowd is a pitiful word to
describe how I felt today the permanence
of your impact is undeniable always has
been but now we have a fancy star to
show for it she really does just show me
how to be better in almost every way as
a father as a person everything and
speaking of cute kids check out a burly
Tatum's Christmas list oh there's a nice
surprise Jenna Dewan Tatum shared the
pic to Instagram and it's clear her and
channing's little one is a big fan of
glitter fairies and well anything purple
[Music]